[Music]
welcome wait for the red light
all right I know podcast Lord gaben that
net I'm gonna crack you know who's this
fine gentleman that we had in the round
once again I'm silly likes x of n
programmer on the game awesome now
Streets of Rage fan favorite we saw it
here last year the leaps and bounds that
you guys have made between last year and
this year is phenomenal to quickly tell
us about we just saw the four player
co-op which is amazing I'll make the
entire Lords will have that uploads game
to edit that played it so let's talk
about that mode first real quick you
know what inspires you guys say you know
let's just go all out or play a local
co-op we I search people who like it who
doesn't want to play for player so we
just and with a new combo system we have
we knew that that it could work like you
know like that it would be interesting
for to to try to tag team played enemies
tunes and and because now it's a it's
widescreen yes fire to all the games so
we have more screen real estate today we
thought it would work so we just put
four player and it works and then we
tweak some stuff so we allowed for
example for a friendly fire to be
switched off oh yes yes because you can
switch it on if you want but at four
players it's very hard to play very
chaotic
now what about difficulty scaling and
relate and also the game in relationship
to the signal is it well it changes it
completely different from a stage wise
or we're playing through the basics
research poor but with four player co-op
and difficulty scaling so it's a same
stage but you do less damage okay
basically so you have an opportunity and
because you you do big combos to enemies
and four player it works quite well in
some situation when you play multiplayer
there are more enemies and you can
always if you want are gonna be
difficulty levels that goal that range
from very easy to so crazy it's like it
so you can spike it if you want if you
if you think it's it's too easy you do
we have achieved mints and in trophies
maybe reward that then level of
difficulty that we make spike yes you
had him reward if you play at higher
difficulty of course that was for play
but we have some other stuff to show the
day right so let's get into what we have
going on today let's get into it so so
we also have new characters that we just
sent out yes Floyd Floyd is Victor he's
a big it's a big guy so a big guy from
these are Maori okay so he's from New
Zealand and so he lost his arms and
doctors and real team robotic arms nice
story transition I like that nice so and
with his arm so he's a grappling
characters of course this can grab our
character he has a cannon in his arm you
can you can do a special and it's the
first character in a Switzer fridge that
can grab an enemy's and walk around I
walk around yes and grab two enemies and
do it listen I'm a max fanboy I love her
at first max wasn't there but I have to
admit same Floyd make me forget if we'd
like to have what hey max it's okay
we got Floyd but your great character
design also since we last saw you
I believe you actuary right
which is Adams daughter and Adam who we
didn't know at the time
last time I interview we just had blaze
and Axl but now we've got the whole team
again out of his daughter so Adam is a
huge fan favorite
we love the design he was he always on
the top of list to return yes and we and
we had to restrain Taurus yes yes yeah
we since the beginning we wanted to have
and especially since we announced the
game so that we saw that everybody
wanted requests if if we if we hesitated
when we announced the game we didn't
hesitate after that nice so we had to
put Adam and it's nice to have the team
for the first one working together
that's all so that's all it's very
interesting because we have Excel and
blaze returning such as that play such
as the same moves more moves but they're
also the same moves that's inter all one
but Adam because it was only Streets of
Rage one it's like a new character yes
so it's a returning character and also a
new character time of the internal of
holy place and the animations that you
guys did I believe had you were playing
with them they were really cool looks
like some dragon animation some yellow
flame like the special moves that he has
look really cool so it like you said it
was almost like reimagining an old
character I had a limited who said cuz
it was only in one game but then now he
gets this whole new moon set to catch up
with everybody that's really cool last
question I got with with that at the
four player was um now I know the new
consoles are coming right and we don't
currently right now four-player local
co-op right two-player online
right at any point is there possibility
of 4 player online maybe with the bigger
culture we see maybe we've seen patches
we focused on getting the game out with
online car with online co-op 2 player so
we can play with a friend if you had a
friend that that you played when you
were little that not in the same city
anymore so now you can play with XIV
remember so that's nice and if you're in
the couch with 4 people you can have a
crazy party so yes yes so that's what we
managed to do and I saw shown a saw so
let's get into a bit Sakhalin of couch
let's get right into let's see what we
got going on today that you're ready to
show us no choice fine - it's fine yeah
towards 5 players right now are you guys
gonna add more characters or unlocks
maybe when you complete stages are they
all available from the start
maybe not everyone is available from the
start but it's gonna gonna be unlocked
very very very fast very fast gadget and
there is cherry we're believers Axl's
daughter be Adams daughter which is also
me to take the classic nice the
animations that you guys have used it
even with him walking you can see what
Adam it is from million range
yes because of him so it's great
animation but by a laser artistic art
director Ben CK yes not here you human
I bet him last year yes yes so now as
far as or as for now we know what's
covered on a multiple multiple platforms
there Xbox Playstation switch now as far
as switch is concerned you know it's a
lesser console well you guys had issues
as far as pawning be able to get pretty
much everything faithfully and the
switch version as well yeah it's gonna
be faithful to the other version now
we'll switch also have the four player
co-op board yes
Wow switch gang now as far as where we
are right now are we at the very
beginning of the game I would assert sub
section of the game here it's level
treat okay so we're about level three
right now yeah sounds good we have Adam
and his dog
Oh to pimp-slap the big guys though even
the enemies man they're so hilarious
vintage Streets of Rage some returning
highs and some new guys I'll say you
guys based up decisions or some new
characters yes our new enemies yes we
wanted to have returned in a new enemy
so you have this guy's a new enemy and
all enemies of their behavior so this
guy has his many his hand in the pockets
yeah all of that elevation so he's
is more stay under distance and a sneaky
car yes
with the head BOTS now these are big ben
is a classic
so funny
big bellies been around for a long time
debuted I believe I remember sheets are
h2 baseball stadium I think I think I
think things will we saw been in yeah oh
yeah just one excuse me are you are
correct you are correct you just looked
better in 242 Heat
tell us about the combo system yeah how
is this work how do you initiate set of
combos so you just have to continue
hitting an enemy so you can hit a
different enemies to call and keep your
own okay but if you get hit if anyone
get hit the brakes - so you bigger the
combo you are you you make the bigger
your points okay I'll get at the end
okay so the most volatile you get but if
you get hit one time in the combo you
you you never exiting so it's a it's how
you have a great player iconic
difference yet okay because you help our
screen select regenerate over time it
will generate if you hit enemies so you
have your helper become green if you use
Y moves also special moves and if you
hit enemies it regenerate but if you get
a hit you lose all your green bar okay
you can grab
now now old-school streets are raised
when the special moves were initiated
vert and it was energy lost at that
point are we still kind of having that
system or it's a special so you see you
have the green bar yes so you lose
energy but you have a chance to regain
it
gotcha gotcha that's cool that's cool
and again now back to classic mode where
friendly fire is back on right yeah yeah
here we are Fred yes and we wanted to
virus the situation for example in this
in this level you're on a line you can't
move in
so and so it's you have to be careful
with the enemies and manage your
distance and like you said the way they
operate a I watch those guys like to
keep their distance
yeah and it's sticky I love it I love it
and I also love the desire that you guys
have like we saw the trail of were
earlier you know also like those stages
like this but they're all kind of
tightly restrictive and you know use a
different kind of aspect to find it
which is pretty cool with the map it's
really what we try to do in this game is
to vary the situation so it's going to
be a bigger map all the time so it's
always fighting but we very situation
for example this boss is Laura so she
she hit Garcia's and they become she
whips the middle shape she whipped into
shape so you have to wait for her and to
to avoid them being more powerful now
that's what we built Sega has given you
guys the green light as far as you know
the characters and things of that nature
like how has it been working with Sega
and just bringing back these classic
enemies classic characters house a bit
working with it right even been great
working with them they they say what
they do is they give us feedback they
say take care that everything stays in
brand that is not too far from what
people have expected what is which are a
child always beats
we had a very good working relationship
with with how do you do that what is
that Isamu that's the star ball in the
special moves so you have to choose when
to use them it's awesome now at least
you make some good points of reference
to Sega and then influence stuff has
there any business if they have a better
situation where they may have pushback
what a design they say hey we don't
think that falls a lot or put a bump or
they've been pretty helpful does
everybody have put but a lot of what we
did and I think but we try to root to
stay faithful to your originals anyway
so let's be so close so close sherry
there we go there we go I love to be
nice like you can still jump over the
characters and like hit them from behind
and stuff like that or is that like
depends on who's the screen side like
jumping at the side of the wall before I
was like I wasn't able to okay depends
so enemies have a tendency to bounce on
the side of the world but when you're
two player maybes I want babies I can go
out of the screen
if it's only if you play two player
because if the one player on the right
is gonna add the camera here but most of
the time and we cannot go out of the
Scotch if so you are you're not gonna
hit enemies out of the screen oh that
was something we wanted to change so
with wall bounce and stuff like that so
for example we scroll with the flow you
can take an enemy and throw him on the
wall and it's got a bounce and then you
can grab it again maybe we're pretty
eager to see what player will find
because you can change a lot of food
together especially for player so this
yeah it is tremendous where it's calm
it's looking phenomenal we are super
excited and as far as right now again we
have to do character
we got the features got play online with
a friend obviously
how's that for the online lobbies and
stuff like that how simple is it to kind
of get that situated to get online with
people it's gonna be very very simple
and obviously is that you start you
start the game okay and you say okay now
I want to play online and and you open
Adobe and then you have your friends
that's gonna come in the lobby and all
you can invite him of course right your
friend right or you can do a public
you can open again and so I can't wait
for anybody to come or you can invite a
friend now that's a two way to go if I
say for example I host the game and can
I start a game and someone join me in
process or we wait in the lobby and then
start together they'll join ya you have
to start together right when you're
played together then you can you can
continue playing and go into other game
modes and surgeries while staying
connected so it's really you bound and
then you can play very good way to
change characters and sell things again
the person who probably be the question
that person who hosts the lobby he could
do we have to up so you have to do a
football player or we can say start at
stage three and then continue one do we
have the app to the fact you have to you
have the flexibility so you if you you
were at stage 3 you can start all over
to take your savegame start a lobby and
conquer someone if I'm join you so it's
really flexible so any see you can any
mode you can play locally you can play
online the same way and so the host is
gonna keep his save game and you have a
someone that comes out also buys a head
of some people that's a great feature so
pretty much the host has that they have
that advantage this is really cool man
Streets of Rage for we are extremely
excited Searles back in the building now
I know it's coming hopefully coming soon
and we we get it close to a release date
anytime so spring it's gonna be this is
a childhood dream I'm very proud of you
guys the temple guard crush Lisak you
this is amazing absolute pleasure to
have interrupt
absolute pleasure she's arranged for
iron law podcasts approved
[Music]
you
[Music]